le canada possède 20% des réserves d'eau
douce de la planète pour plusieurs c'est
une ressource quasi inépuisable c'est ce
qui explique peut-être pourquoi nous
sommes les plus grands consommateurs
d'eau au monde et aussi pourquoi très
peu de politiques existent pour gérer
cette ressource
pourtant les pénuries d'eau sont déjà
bien réelle à plusieurs endroits au pays
[Musique]
une école c'est moche
normalement cette récolte atteindrait ma
taille
si on est chanceux
nous aurons un tiers de notre rendement
moyen c'était
[Musique]
une auto a beau être optimiste de nature
le manque d'eau commence à peser lourd
sur son moral
ce fermier du sud de l'alberta dépend de
la pluie pour ses cultures mais au début
juillet 2021 la pluie se fait rare et il
fait chaud très chaud
nous savons que nous sommes dans un
climat plus sec c'est dans le sud de
l'alberta nous disons que nous cultivons
dans un désert et nous y sommes habitués
aux lyonnais
[Musique]
il est normal de connaître deux années
de sécheresse consécutive mais au cours
des cinq dernières années nous en avons
eu quatre l'an dernier nous avons eu une
excellente récolte mais nous voilà
encore en période de sécheresse a new
show famille c'est très inhabituel pour
moi
c'est sans précédent nous connaissons
une sécheresse d'un océan à l'autre from
coast to coast
de l'île de vancouver aux prairies
jusqu'à l'ontario et le sud du québec
d'habitude on une sécheresse qui va
durer un mois deux mois maximum et le
stade mais on a pris quatre mois
consécutifs
cette année c'est incroyable en fait on
a vu des bons niveaux record on n'avait
jamais observées ce
qui est encore plus surprenant c'est
cette canicule record qui a accompagné
cette sécheresse
strout
on a eu trois jours de ce fêtard 47
degrés ici un maximum
[Musique]
l'hydrologue john pommereuil est une
sommité mondiale en études de l'eau
depuis des années il dirige des
recherches sur l'eau partout dans le
monde au canada ils travaillent surtout
dans les rocheuses
c'est un centre de recherche que nous
avons établies dans les rocheuses
canadiennes
nous sommes au point le plus élevé du
bassin de la rivière saskatchewan
l'eau qui s'écoule ici fourni de 70 à 80
% du débit de tous les affluents de la
rivière saskatchewan
le bassin hydrographique de la rivière
saskatchewan est vaste et très important
plusieurs de ces rivières prennent leur
source dans les rocheuses qu elle dévale
en direction des prairies alimentant au
passage les villes de calgary edmonton
en eau potable de là elle traverse
l'alberta la saskatchewan et le manitoba
avant de se jeter dans le lac winnipeg
qui se déverse en direction de
l'habitude sont
[Musique]
fiers hérite d'une et terres agricoles
elles fournissent de l'eau potable et de
l'électricité aux villes
en plus d'alimenter tous les écosystèmes
aux alentours
[Musique]
quand vous allez à saskatoon et que vous
voyez la rivière saskatchewan sud
seulement 1 % du débit de cette rivière
provient de la saskatchewan
le reste vient d'ici
les rocheuses sont donc une immense
réserve d'eau
la quantité des précipitations les
accumulations de neige et la qualité des
glaciers ont un impact direct sur les
niveaux d'eau partout dans l'ouest
canadien est l'équipe de john pommereuil
étudient cette réserve d'eau
[Musique]
c'est un observatoire hydrologiques nous
surveillons la source des cours d'eau
grâce aux accumulations de neige et aux
glaciers dans les montagnes
ici de la glace et du pergélisol et à
mesure que ceux-ci font dès que la pluie
tombe cela favorise le débit des cours
d'eau
[Musique]
nous avons une multitude d'instruments
de mesures climatiques et
météorologiques
nous mesurons l'épaisseur et la densité
de la neige et la rapidité de la fente
de celle ci
il s'agit donc probablement dus ces deux
mesures de neige le plus instrumenté au
canada
les données recueillies par tous ces
instruments confirme que les changements
climatiques ont un impact sur le régime
hydrologique des rocheuses grâce à ces
données l'équipe peut concevoir des
modèles et des simulations et ainsi
faire des prévisions hydrologiques et
tout cela n'a rien de rassurant
nous risquons d'avoir un peu plus de
précipitations en moyenne dans les
rocheuses canadiennes mais des
conditions beaucoup plus chaude beaucoup
moins de neige est beaucoup plus de
pluie
les glaciers auront essentiellement
disparu d'ici la fin du siècle
effondrons rapidement au cours des
prochaines décennies
le glacier petto
voici un parfait exemple de l'impact des
changements climatiques
ce glacier est la source du lac petto
l'une des plus belles cartes postales
des rocheuses
c'est le premier glacis au monde à faire
l'objet d'une surveillance intensive et
ce suivi montre une des glaciations si
rapide que son nez stupéfiants
en 1965 je me serais tenu ici à deux
cents mètres plus haut en altitude
et vous voyez la crête là-bas et bien à
ce moment-là on pouvait marcher
directement sur la glace
cela démontre à la fois visuellement et
scientifiquement l'impact des
changements climatiques
ce nom
nous sommes au bord d'une crevasse où le
glacier se brise cela aurait été une
promenade assez agréable il ya quelques
années à peine mais il y a un an il y a
eu un effondrement
pour un glacier s'est incroyablement
rapide
la chaleur excessive qui a frappé
l'ouest du pays à l'été 2000 21 a eu un
effet radical sur le glacier
[Musique]
nous avons enregistré des températures
de 14 degrés celsius sur la glace ici ce
qui est extrêmement chaud pour un
glacier les vents ils sont généralement
quelques degrés au dessus de zéro
et puis descendre et de la suie
provenant d'un incendie en
colombie-britannique se sont déposés sur
le glacier et en ont assombri la surface
ensuite dézinguer des bactéries ont
rendu la glace encore plus sombre cette
glace noire font très rapidement
estime que le glacier aura perdu cette
année seulement environ 7 mètres ce qui
est la plus importante perte à ce jour
[Musique]
le glacier petto comme la centaine de
glaciers encore présents dans les
rocheuses potier les accumulations de
neige et cette neige quand elles font
fournit le débit des rivières le glacier
agit comme un thermostat qui contrôle la
température
cela permet de ralentir la fonte de la
neige
[Musique]
mais durant une année de sécheresse
comme celle de 2021 lorsque toutes les
autres sources de débit des rivières se
sont
alors la fonte des glaces est tout ce
qui nous reste pour soutenir le débit
des rivières
[Musique]
la fonte du glacier petto et dramatique
avec les prévisions des changements
climatiques voilà peut être un mauvais
présage pour les niveaux d'eau dans
l'ouest du pays
[Musique]
pour moi c'est apocalyptique ce que nous
voyons ici c'est une des glaciations
bien plus rapide que tout ce que nous
avions anticipé
nous savions déjà que ce glacier
n'allait pas survivre au 21ème siècle
mais là nous le voyons fondre beaucoup
plus tôt que prévu je ne pense pas qu'il
va se rendre en 2050 l'ont probablement
même pas en 2030
tout ça rend notre approvisionnement en
eau très précaire
[Musique]
e